s
féminin, Billie Jean King.
Elle a accepté de parler
de sa propre expérience, pour
encourager les plus jeunes.
Yasmine Mehdi y était.
- Naomi Osaka dit stop.
- L'été dernier, le cas Naomi
Osaka ébranlait le monde
du tennis. Lchchampionne se
retirait du tournoi de Roland-
Garros, en évoquant sa santé
mentale fragile. Un retrait
inattendu, qui révélait un sujet
tabou : celui des troubles
psychologiques chez
leatathlètes.
Un an plus tard, la question
est toujours d'actualité
Pendant cette conférence
en marge de l'Omnium Banque
Nationale, les athlètes
discutent d'équité des genres
et de santé mentale après cette
véritable prise de conscience
dans le monde  s sport.
(applaudissements)
L'une des panélistes,
la légende du tennis Billie Jean
King. L'ancienne numéro 1 a
remporté un total de 39 titres
du Grand Chelem en carrière,
elle est aussi connue pour son
militantisme en faveur du sport
féminin. En 1973, Billie battait
l'ancien numéro un masculin,
bbbby Rings lors d'un match
événement surnommé la bataille
des sexes.
Pendant son allocution, Billie
Jean a parlé de sa propre santé
mentale.
Sur le court, les questions
sur la santé mentale continuent
aussi de rebondir. Notamment
pour Bianca Andreescu de retour
à Toronto, elle qui a pris
une pause après avoir remporté
le US open, en 2019.
La jeune Leylah Fernandez
aussi, veut prioriser sa santé
mentale.
LEYLAH FERNANDEZ, joueuse tennis
- Si, mentalement, je peux
être forte dans des moments
difficiles, le corps va pouvoir
suivre un peu plus facilement.
Alos, je n'ai pas besoin de
me battre contre moi-même.
- C'est que je trouve qu'ils
donnent l'exemple...
- De plus en plus, ces questions
de santé mentale préoccupent
les organisations sportives.
Marie-France Mercier évolue
dans le monde du tennis depuis
presque 20 ans. Elle aussi
constate une réelle prise
de conscience.
MARIE-FRANCE MERCIER, dir. form.
entraîneurs, Tennis Canada
- Je pense que ça a toujours é
un peu présent. La différence,
c'est que là, on le dit à voix
haute. Alors... on le dit à voix
haute parce que les gens sont
prêts à passer à l'action.
- Et ce n'est pas qulele tennis.
L'olympienne Stéphanie Labbé
a remporté l'or ecec l'équipe
canadienne de soccer à Tokyo.
Inspirée par Naomi Osaka et
Simone Biles, elle s'est aussi
confiée sur ces épisodes de
dépression. Une façon, dit-elle
d'insperer d'autres athlètes.
Des conversations qui évoluent,
alors que de plus en plus
d'athlètes sont prêts à montrer
l'envers de la médaille :
la pression qui augmente
avec l'exigence de toujours
performer.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Toronto